not many men can we stand my punch punch
obviously obviously for sure got a set
got a set of hair on them black belts
and chick Chicken Heads uh I think you'd
be surprised I think you'd be surprised
AB Kenny Fight Club Fight Club Fight
Club kids got a PE on peace onle one two
Cutie Pies I still got it baby lift your
shield and now from the on it studios in
Pia Vista California it is the moment
you've been waiting for the fighter and
the kid is coming at you
live no no we're not live that doesn't
matter sounds better when you say live
but we're not live we don't do shut up
man and now it's the fighter and the kid
Li not shut not live oh look who's back
I'm back man the kid is back
I feel like I haven't seen you well you
haven't and I'll tell you something I
was in Salt Lake City and the Air's a
little dry so my face may look may look
a little bit of a pruned up pruned up a
little bit you look like you need a warm
glass of milk and a hot nap well here's
the thing man by nap I mean days of just
pure rest and and some cucumbers on my
eyes now listen up and a mud mask and a
mud mask Whitener well here's the here's
the thing I when it's cold like this and
it's the fall I feel like there's a new
there's a new sort of there new
possibilities out there I feel as though
you know it's kind of a rebirth like a
changing yeah some say skin feels skin
feels tighter my my body feels like it's
uh it's more energized got more of a pep
little bit bit of a bounce to my step
fall yeah I feel like I want to shed I
feel like I want to shed some of my uh
the expectations like an old snake like
an old dirty snake dude I want I can't
believe you just use that metaphor I
want to shed my scales a little bit cuz
cuz I'm I'm an old dirty snake and and
and you know if you saw if you saw my
piece right now looks like it's been
through a war what with all the veins
calluses and probably a couple bumps I
can't explain that's not the point
that's not the point the thing is I do
want to I do want to shed some scales
and I feel like I'm always expected to
be like a father with two kids and a
husband and be all monogamous and you
know and be cool and friendly to
everyone I got to set an example stand
in line keep my voice down be mannered
but sometimes you're like Spider-Man
yeah sometimes I just want to I want to
let loose I want to run I want to scream
I want to bang a guy whatever it might
be that happens Li there are no
limitations you got to shed that skin
sometimes like you're rolling jits for
example rolling jits call but I'm just
saying if you're rolling
jits and and and maybe you got a guy
under you who's a little weaker maybe
not as experienced as you up the belt
and maybe his Chin's not as shed his
skin by shed his skin I mean well all
I'm saying is I'm imposing a will on him
now now you know you know from watching
me roll you know that if I'm controlling
a man I'm wear him like a sweater you
know how I wear him like a sweater you
we call it backpacking what backpack you
jump on the back and you're like a
you're like a full I'm an octopus well
what were you going to say I was going
to say you're full like college backpack
just full of all those books I'm College
backpack College backpack backp you're
the old REI backpack oh I like that I'm
backpacking them yeah you're the old uh
what are those backpacks called what
what starts with a J our listeners like
come on it's called were they ohow God
maybe am I a rook sack what am I but
anyway I'm I'm you guys I'm tight I'm
tight to his body tight to his body like
a turtle yeah I'm wearing him like a
sweater now if he's under me and I'm
pinning him down you know I'm going
chest chest to chest and probably
probably hips to hips well hold on for a
second sir I don't know that guy that
well and you know I'm a straight guy
however is a new season there are no
limitations old snake is shedding his
scales so if I start to impose my will
and he's having trouble breathing he's
going I might mistaken that that might
signal a prey drive inside me you know
what I mean by prey drive might signal a
prey drive he's in distress he's making
distress signals I might confuse
distress signals for sex signals oh wow
I would want to roll with you oh well no
you don't the old snake no cuz the SN
God who's going tooll the old
snake get in trouble to jam his dick in
your mouth well hold on now hold on I'm
face to face my I'm chest to chest hard
you jump on top mount full if he's
wearing a single at and I pull it to the
side okay you know what man I'm just
saying hey fall got you all crazy sure
did you spring does this you're kind
it's kind of contradicting but I hear
you he's making them distress signals
but I'm confusing them for sex sign okay
well you're ex can't breathe I'm
imposing my will and and all of a sudden
hey I might be an old snake but this is
a snake
too okay okay well No One's Gonna Roll
with you ever now you're gonna be banned
from every gym in America why a it's the
old snake yeah man you got to be careful
try watch out for the old thing try
checking your oil he'll he'll engage
straight and he comes out of it a little
bit different he comes out different it
depends on the season it depends on the
season the blood moon sure now you ever
been you're a big man you bit of a
gorilla you ever held a man down you've
held a couple guys down who are given
distress signals I you've done that when
you start to squeeze the life out of
them oh yeah has it ever signal a prey
drive inside you God I can't it sure
hasn't bro no doesn't matter on the
season either never felt a little rush
little little rush downstairs God never
just some Harlequin romance blood that
just kind of pumps through the let me
think nope never okay never had sorry
never had a guy who's smelled nice long
hair real smooth
cheeks no doesn't doesn't ring any B no
with an apple bottom or anything like
that take again it's just not coming
together for me me neither hey me
neither me Nei how how was Utah brother
it was good man was it Utah Utah Utah is
a beautiful place it's Mormon so what
happens in a Mormon town is that they
it's so clean people are so polite
they're so nice everything about it
Stevie blue eyes was like dude this
place people are so nice 's nice it's
really nice and what what I thought was
interesting is that like we live in a
world where you can't be Prejudice to
anybody well they can't be Prejudice you
know what I'm saying only I'm saying I'm
saying in in Los Angeles you got to be
careful you know New York if you say
anything racist or whatever sure but
when you when you go to Utah and you get
a lot of Los angelenos who say things
like careful of those Mormons see it's
kind of still acceptable to be prejudice
against morm or religious people and I
was like really I had somebody say it
who shall remain them and said you going
to you going there Mormons huh careful
and careful like what what are they
going to do they might murder me are
they a murderous lot I might get stabbed
it was weird there could be like some
head Mormon guy who's like super gay and
he wants you part of his I don't know
you know what part of and I'm I'm part
of his Squad Squad he's looking for an
old snake The Grateful type it is fall
well see I don't I don't get that same
urge I do I like Utah I like it too it's
so white it's pretty white although
there are lot of sim a lot of sim and
tongin there you know that there are
yeah yeah that's why BYU Utah uh there's
a ton of them there yeah because I think
because because they do an outreach
program there and if you if you convert
to the Church of Latter-day Saints you
can get I think automatic US citizenship
or something I have a family who is
Mormon and I think the the mom's not
Mormon the daughters are one of but when
she got married in the the Church of
Mormon if you're not Mormon you can't
she had to watch from like the outskirts
like you can't go into the church unless
yeah yeah even during the weddings like
she was on the outside like how'd it go
wow it's crazy right yeah well you know
listen to each his own to each his own
I'll probably stay out of that now what
did you do besides set up the new studio
you did a lot of the work maybe all of
it maybe all the work by the way ion was
Brandon was doing all the stuff and I
was shooting and I came I I drove back
and I apologize for missing all these
shows guys I drove back and he's there
with my buddy Court who's amazing and
he's a designer the best guy in the
world best guy in the world he's the
best guy in the it off the best guy in
the world he's he's setting up our
studio and I come in and I start making
suggestions throwing a monkey wrench
into the works because you got to know
Brenan he's got things buttoned down and
finally you go hey hey hey hey are you
the worst have you met my partner the
worst will you just come in called me
the worst the worst I asked Court I'm
like have you met my partner the worst
have you met this
guy cuz Court's the you know he's a set
designer he does some ridiculous stuff
so me and him were going through all of
it we're done it's over Brian shows up
at the goes yeah I know it looks good
what if we did I'm like all right man
even Court's like God damn it you know
what's funny you just got to throw
something in when you throw when you get
frustrated with me what's funny is that
I think it's very it's interesting
because you're i i i something weird
happens because you're very big right
very strong so in caveman days you could
you could throw you could do what a
Silverback does in a community if you
look at Silverbacks or the the bull the
Bull male in uh chimpanzee cult uh you
know colonies they will once in a while
just go off to into a rage beat the sh
but they'll beat the [__] out of
whoever's closest to them they'll just
be like am I and just kick sh maybe kick
the [__] out of a like it could be a
woman could be a a female could be a
male could be even an adolescent a
little baby so they they freak out and
everybody's like oh my God somebody
usually just to establish order they'll
just they'll just have a tantrum they'll
have an a testosterone overload in a
tantrum and somebody gets killed if
you're friend to me doing I've never
once ever used any form of physical and
that's what's funny about you is that
you you you you're not like that and you
would never be so what happens is you're
this giant guy who can't have the
chimpanzee tantrum so you end up you end
up having to be like and you get
exasperated the way an intellectual
would yeah I get frustrated and for I
don't know if I'd be the same way I
might just be a bit of a bu might start
shoving you around a little bit I I
think it then it's you know this is just
going through the ups and downs of
owning a business together you know with
with Fox yeah it's not that it was
unexpected it's just we have to make
moves fast so we had that going going
going you know so it it doesn't screw us
over it's just you got to make moves
fast which I I like being under pressure
I like getting work done but you can't
the Stray From the course you got to
stay straight ah like you got to go man
I tend to be distracted I'm like a bird
dog if I see a bird I'm going to go
what's out and I see another bird and I
kick over there I'm a swivel head no if
if we left the St up to you it'd be done
in oh March 2021 I'm svel head it's a
problem but that's why this works if you
were the guy who are like we need to do
this we should do this this I'm like I
think it would be a nightmare no no no
it's a good that I'm not yeah I don't
have no that's why this works I stay out
of the way that's why I'm so excited for
it the F so everything's basically done
our new producer um the furniture and
everything gets delivered today there'll
be some you know we're going to add
stuff on I might have bought a zebra
head that's mounted on the wall yeah
it's a man cave son couple one two
zebras got a zebra heads up it's a fake
one though don't hate me it's a fake a
fake it looks real or did I go out and
kill one with my bare hands we go a
zebra Farm in Northern California pay to
shoot one and saw its head off or or did
I get behind it and just put my old
fingers in his little nose nose and then
shut those yellow ass teeth listen you
strong guy not a shot you could do that
to a zra a single shot you're seen it
run away from a z a line just kicking in
the face yeah I wonder if you were to if
you were to grab a zebra and put its
snout in a head lock and hold on he
would fck me off with the quickness that
that ain't happening but the so the
studio should be done tonight with
everything in the as far as transfer and
all our stuff from
Fox that would be a nightmare no matter
what happened but the holidays makes it
a little worse because everyone's on
break so uh we don't need to start a new
channel we don't do anything like that
iTunes uh I don't know when this is
going to go up but iTunes should be up
today and then Stitcher SoundCloud takes
a little longer that be later in the
week we're launching uh number two of
the fighting the kid cartoon animation
series today as well it's a funny story
fight story Brian I what happened to us
oh yeah but and then we'll be back in
the studio Wednesday will be our first
show in our new studio we got Rob Rob
cordry uh I think so I love very funny
from children's hospital hospital well
old school um either way we'll be we'll
be up and running though I'm excited for
it man yeah dude Independence flying
solo as they say flying solo flying solo
flying solo I've always wondered when
you get your pilot's license and you you
learn how to fly and there's always a
pilot next to you and then then they put
you in that plane alone that must be a
little scary yeah it's up to you you
know what that's like that's like doing
firing the kid lies with Brian Ken and
the next thing you know you're on the
Marquee at the Laugh Factory and you
don't have your co-pilot oh yeah oh yeah
and by the way that's very true you're
on the Marquee of the Laugh Factory what
the hell com no business doing no uh
Laugh Factory Laugh Factory and yeah
because you have a draw you have an
audience and now now you're hey you you
got thrown in deep water right away it's
a little bit like the UFC oh how many
fights you had oh go go fight Roy J uh
Roy Nelson go might as well been Roy
Jones you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah uh that I mean it seems to be a
common theme in my life just got adapt
and I'm excited man but that that that
was the most nervous I've been I took a
picture CU last time I was there I think
I saw you there a while ago but the
previous time I was there was probably
10 years ago when my buddy uh Joe
glenstein and myself were out here in
Los Angeles and uh we went with our
girls at the time to the laugh actory
cuz Dan Cook was there and it it's
Heyday Dan this 10 years oh he's the
biggest thing Chris Rock at you know at
the time he's as big as they get so we
saw him there so I'm walking up I had no
idea I was on the Marquee I have no
business being up there don't get
twisted I realize what's going on here
so I walk up and I take a picture I sent
to my buddy CL and went remember the
last time we were here and he goes holy
[__] I went craziness I'll let you know
how God damn it how weird is that well
life is life is weird like that when you
just [__] I think though man you know
there's this thing where you you feel
something it's a crazy idea you
shouldn't do it it makes no sense you do
it anyway you you're terrified you keep
taking the steps a lot of times I think
that works out a lot of times when
you're terrified if you have the if
you'll you'll find a way if you really
want it it should scare you like you
always say if if your goals don't scare
they're not big enough I I think for me
you know there's there's obviously a
self-belief in my you know in what I'm
doing otherwise I wouldn't get up there
yeah but you know yeah but self-belief
also comes from what preparation correct
and from rehearsal what' Conor McGregor
say I was like how the hell did you
become this confident my work ethic I
was like but everybody works hard he
goes they think they work hard yeah you
know I mean so I think a certain level
of uh you know rehearsal constant
attention obsession will create
a a certain amount of confidence doesn't
mean you're not going to be afraid no
and it could be a and this happens all
the time it's a self belief confidence
which sometimes not true you know where
you're a little bit out of your lane
everybody has doubts for oh yeah oh yeah
everyone for for me you know CU like I
said I get what's going on here I have
no business being up there it's this
fast you but I can make some people
laugh and they keep inviting me back to
Comedy Store La Factory I'm actually at
The Comedy Store Tuesday night with uh
Bert Cher
Tri and then Sunday night are people
laughing when you go up there yes then
you have business being up there yeah
are you making people laugh for 10
minutes I think so then you belong there
otherwise they would invite me back you
have business they would inv invite me
back well also the reason that you're a
draw is because you've been doing a
podcast and we've been making people
laugh for 200 episodes well but I'm also
I'm next to you every goddamn day so
10,000 hours okay that's also like me
saying uh you know is saying well you
you I was talk about how I'm making a
lot of money on this podcast and people
who are in the business they don't
understand yet they like well how are
you making money I go well sponsors and
they go dude how did you and merchandise
they go and they go dude I didn't know
you were a businessman I go hey I'm not
you should just run I don't do anything
you should just run I do I have a
business but I got a business partner
does all
work but by what I'm saying is that yeah
whatever the case whatever the case
symbiotic relationship we figure it out
yes yes surround yourself with people
that you know make you better so yes but
you know what what's funny about that is
that I uh I do not come to your shows I
stay away now because the umbilical C
cord has been cut and by the way when I
saw on Instagram you on the [__]
Marquee your [__] flyer um I didn't
know anything about it I'm like what
tomorrow tomorrow at the [__] Comedy
Store the [__] is this how about am I on
the show I look around I'm like I didn't
hear anything about agent oh talk my
agent okay there you go step inside huh
yeah I felt I felt your palm on my face
you move me aside and I was like the
[__] is this I just got to do my own
thing Man flying flying solo huh got
your wings do you got your feathers out
scary you jump out of the nest and you
flopping around jumping out of the nest
you can't be regurgitating that food
anymore mom's got his worms my mom's got
her worms right here where's your
where's your beat be open got my own
worms you're going to get your own worms
my own worms going to get your own
[__] worm my old wings Wings what
else going on brother um what else is
going on I'm raising kids besid besides
the the stress of the student I've been
so stressed man I'm even at 32 I think
I'm 32 maybe 33 yeah [__] face was
breaking out couldn't sleep yeah cuz
that you're at the mercy of iTunes
Stitcher SoundCloud Fox transitioning
and transfering everything over so when
you don't have power you know like you
all right so in fighting or even in
comedy if you want to get up there you
can find spots to get up there like you
can take control of your career TV is a
little different obviously you know how
it is right now I'm on pins and Eels
waiting to get a green light from two
shows that I can deal that I knew about
right this I I was like oh we'll just
we'll leave and then we just have our
passwords and codes and we just upload
if we don't skip a beat yeah huh no well
no you have about 300 something odd
episodes that we'd have to transfer over
it's a large process it really is man
and you're at the mercy what do you
think what do you think causes the
stress is it your L your inability to
control your destiny your life cuz cuz
the way this is our baby especially this
is my baby right like this is this is
well the big with this and my biggest
stress came from the fact that I was you
know doing these two TV shows I'm
shooting a show I'm acting on TV I have
to miss the podcast I know I know what
my constant is though which is my
podcast so it kills me that's stressful
but you know I'm always good with that
and it's going to happen if either one
of these shows go you're going to have
to do it by yourself will be terrible
but you will do it sir you will [__]
do it I will do it you get your dad on
you get talk about government we'll
bring him on we'll talk about
intellectual [__] but here's what I
here's what I the way I looked at it the
way I calm down was I was like look man
we're gonna have hiccups but the show
goes on we always we're gonna have the
show for a long time doing the show for
a long time got bills I mean no but also
I love doing it no I love doing it it's
it's just stressful and listen and I the
fans feel the same way like anytime
there's a change it's tough man I cuz
you don't think I love going to Fox
anymore knowing everything was there
stuff like that but there comes a time
where you're just like business-wise and
our goals it's probably time to do our
own thing and of course we're scared but
and everything's different right now
we're at a temporary Studio which you
know is is tough too cuz and then you're
building a new one so it's all these
things and and again it's it's not knock
on you but a lot of it's on my shoulders
to get the Studio done and hire our new
producer which we did and find this
other intern and make sure it's the way
we want to look and all this other these
details that you don't think of details
the details you don't even think of but
uh somebody's got to solve those
problems you do you just got to keep
going but again change you're always
like God I I hope it would you say the
devil like like when people are trying
to like one of the things I've noticed
as I get older is that details are
almost all matter it's everything the
big stuff the big changes is like if
that's obvious well they were talking
about the difference between the number
one hun tennis player in the world and
the number one tennis player or like or
the number 10 number 10 tennis number
one if you watch them both play hitting
a ball you would not be able to tell the
difference they crush the ball number
humed guy is killer he's a beast
athletic a monster it's the tiny details
it's the in their training in their
mindset in the tiny adjustments they're
always making that you couldn't see
unless you were well you look at the
Olympics too I mean look at the WR lers
or anything like that like the the
difference in Talent is really not I
mean it's just I mean so Mon it's so
small the in world right yeah yeah and
it's so what's that difference well like
when I when I did a round with DC a few
rounds with DC it's just like I know or
or even Pat cumins who's amazing wrest
at Penn State like I've wrestled tons of
guys like brilliant guys who are all
American whatever but when you get to a
world class level you they're going to
do different setups it's going to be the
smallest difference that that they get
the takeown or where usually a guy you
give him a leg and you like enjoy that
I'm just going to whizzer in and you're
I'm going to sprawl where they eat that
stuff a lot they know that's what you're
going to do they're faster they're
always one step ahead cuz they've seen
it one jillion times they just do it
different and and everything doesn't
have to be perfect or maybe when they uh
clasp their hands together you know some
guys it take a second to clasp them that
Olympic level CH like that opening is so
small to get to where they got to get
and that that they say is a function of
like you said like people a lot of
things say well it's technique yes but
it's also it is they've been there so
many times that they are ahead of you
that they are able to anticipate what
you're going to do before you do itun
skills now it's literally part of them
like the extension of them like that mov
is as natural to them as it is for you
to walk right like it's just what they
do they see the opening when most people
go there's a leg I'm going to go here
all right my hands are here they don't
think about it yeah boom
yep your boy Joey janor right uh who's
our our buddy who Joe you know the guy
who made a billion dollars really who
lives in London oh yeah yeah so Joe was
training and riding in Eventing if you
look at horseback riding Sports
Illustrated had Eventing is the most
dangerous sport in the world cuz in one
year six people died right he died cuz
the horse falls on the horse falls on
you I was at an event with him with that
he was running in that he was riding in
and somebody died right there they hell
acted her out or she didn't make it so
it's a really dangerous sport where the
jumps are fixed I swear to God you're
jumping over cars I'm not exaggerating
the horse is jumping over things horse
yeah and and it's a it's a race and
everything else and so the horse fell on
him he' had three accidents and the
horse fell on him and he's trying to
make the Olympic team and this is how
intense he is and the horse fell on him
and he he went into cardiac arrest I
think and then they had to like I mean
literally crush his sternum and he was
in the hospital and two Olympians came
to him one is a world champion and
another was a silver medalist and they
both came to his hospital bed and they
said you have to quit and they and he
said why they said because you're going
to die and he said what what are you
talking about he said you're making
mistakes that we were making when we
were much younger you are not there's no
way you can catch up you're really
ballsy but because you haven't been
riding as long as we are you're making
subtle mistakes that are going to get
you killed and there's no way to catch
up on it how about that [__] and that's
why he stopped that's why he go smart
though huh you think ride horses why
when Aire when 1200lb horse falls on you
that's not a good I an idea just make a
[__] Avatar thing where you're like
computery riding horses and you're a
badass let's not do it you have a
billion doll he's riding with the world
champion BL Tate okay of course New Zeal
he's riding they're riding they're just
kind of like trouting along the horse
for whatever reason bl's leaning forward
the horse for goes and Rears back and
the top of that horse's head like a whip
hits the good dude in the face he it
broke his entire the half of his face
half of his face looked like some
somebody had thrown a
softball like cyborg when you got KN in
the face yeah like you were playing
dodgeball with a bowling ball and a
gorilla threw it at your [__] face
okay so he goes Kad like that and looks
at my buddy my buddy goes your face is
caved in like have your face escaped in
he looks he goes it is and basically
Falls over J and he had to have the
entire face let's not do that hey horses
pick up a goddamn basketball yeah horse
horse doing horse now try riding a zebra
enjoy that ride yeah those things Buck
You Buck you they Buck you I'd love a
zebra you get bucked I'd love a zebra
man you'd ride a would you ride a zebra
for how much money would I have to get
I'm not I'm like I I love squeezing a
horse's nose I like a nice crisp clean
zebra cuz they're pretty bite you you
know that you know that you're talking
about horses oh no no I'm talking about
a zebra oh you didn't know that well
well the horses well too no my my
stepmom's friend they're super into
horses out there in Colorado and this is
years ago bitter titty bitter titty oh
Jesus bit and they have the them dull
dull teeth dull flat grass flat teeth
big smell like [__] bit front teeth it's
a front tooth bite bit titty up now this
was I was a kid when it happened I want
to say she lost the titty oh Christ they
can put implants in but I'm pretty sure
she lost titty bit that thing off like
an old grape on a vine stop it well now
so so so my wife my wife re bent over
and and she said oh somebody just
shocked me no that's no no Mr H gave her
a big old bite on the ass she had her
ass looked like a bad wound's vagina a
while she's lucky she got out Al alive
she got her she's lucky Mr hands the
horse didn't come up behind with that
big old I said I I sent the picture to
Dove David off I sent the picture of of
how black and blue that ass was and he
had to pull over because he was laughing
so hard meanwhile didn't feel so good I
don't [__] with horses man beautiful
creature now a horse will reach out bite
you and let go usually zebra apparently
zebra according to Jared Diamond uh
zebra will will hold on to you hold on
to you shake just like a dog will hold
on to you and not let you go I don't
[__] okay that's an African horse big
difference between African horses we
talking about a
wild there's a reason why genas Khan
wasn't ring a zebra for God's sakes even
even the Mongols didn't
gong that's right they don't suck on the
tea that's why we're a couple one two
zebras Mongols lived off the blood of
their horse and the milk of their horse
primarily through the desert hurting
cultures Bo um how was your Thanksgiving
how was that again I don't know why we
do it man how was that Dr high ass bird
can I tell you something God is there
any can we please mix it up I I got a
bird from Whole Foods cuz our oven was
acting up my wife made a big old organic
turkey breast rubbed it down with some
salt and pepper I get it and did it for
a long time and it was the best turkey
I've ever had now sure now for the most
part you can keep turkey you can keep
[__] turkey cuz you told I told you I
ate wild turkey with Joe Rogan we
dressed it in the field and it tastes
just like that same turkey you ate on
Thanksgiving they all taste the same
wish we could mix Bland Bland and white
I wish we could mix it up man I'm sick
of those dry ass Birds you're going to
Bora bore for uh yeah I'm going to
Brando Island brother now that's a very
exclusive Resort now how that's where
your boy at yeah guess who's paying for
that Daddy yeah Daddy's paying for that
taking the whole family God damn oh yeah
it's going to cost him into six figures
I'm sure what oh yeah you guys fly in
private hey I don't care no no we fly
commercial must be nice big dad well big
the big man 76 and uh his goal is to die
broke spend it that's one way to do it
yeah you guys are flying first class to
Bora bore no first class is a little too
much how do you get there we'll fly
we'll fly coach you go here to I don't
know where you go here to Miami you got
to take two planes and then a boat and
then a cab and then El Chapo built a
tunnel that you have to crawl on your on
your Tomy by the time you get there my
joke is by the time you get there you're
older and divorced let me guess uh sand
uh Clear Water um Sun you know what I'll
be honest with dude it's the best beach
you've ever
seen on vacation you know me I'm not I'm
like you I'm not good on vacation I want
to work however a scuba dive a scuba
dive a scuba dive of sharks I ride
sharks I ride them well you're ly I I
ride them unless Daddy's paying those
sharks off not to bite you let explain
to you I grabbed onto a lemon sharks fin
and I got a video that doesn't count lar
don't count it's 11 foot lemon shark
don't count 11 12 15t lemon shark that'd
be the biggest lemon 23t L 30 foot lemon
shark yep and you know don't count they
don't count I SW unless it's bull tiger
great white or moo yeah I don't want to
[__] hair don't hey I'm telling you
now do not send me a video of you
touching a lemon shark when you come
back I will bite your dick like a dull
horse if you send me any videos of lame
fish unless it can kill me do not send
me a [__] video so true oh that pie
me it's so true that's why at the zoo if
it doesn't kill me I'm probably not
going to stop and and Linger on the
exhibit as soon as I get to the zoo like
doesn't say anything to Zo went through
it lion check tiger check Panda I've
seen pandas [__] people up check polar
bear definitely seeing that that's about
it it's going to be a quick day they
didn't have the crocodiles at the time
the [__] day off did you know that no
yeah some get the day off what do you
mean day off I guess they you [__]
show me that [__] lizard I paid my
money I don't what's the Croc need is
privacy guess they have no feelings Croc
have no feelings and then you can't yell
on the pandas we've talked about this
before she goes I'm you know me I'm loud
dude and coming from a lion pissing on
people she goes sh Panda now now we
we're telling everyone don't raise your
voice around the panda I'm like what the
[__] is going on here I look in there he
just snacking on B uh bamboo Bamboo a
baboon he's just snacking on a bab well
then I'd be quiet yeah because that
would draw my attention but they're
they're they're herbivores isn't that
weird you you have to be [__] quiet
around the panda go to the zoo they shut
it there's literally a line out before a
lady with a mic on going please lower
your voice no yell no flash out what
about the other animals well the
mountain gorilla I love the mountain
gorillas because the mountain gorilla is
first of all to watch them wrestle with
each other and watch very rare yeah I
saw it I was watching the baby good
technique grany rolls and everything
really good technique hey did you see my
post uh for uh Bruns and Whitaker
amazing fight amazing fight yeah the
card was [__] shout out to my boy won
did Brunson win so check it out so
Brunson versus Whitaker and Brunson was
actually favored Whitaker's from
Australia so it's in his hometown home
Home Country right so the crowd's going
nuts for him the pace Brunson set I was
like does he not realize that it's 25
minutes what is he there's no way he
survived 25 minutes he was running
straightforward and it it's worked for
him to this point he's on this crazy win
streak he's rank I think whatever seven
or eight in the world at middleweight
like it's been wrestling pedigree I'm
not sure strike he's known as a striker
though although he did try taking down
Whitaker but he's known for his kind of
uh wild style so he sprinted at Whitaker
the intensity and Pace he said I'm like
oh my God he's either a going to knock
this dude out and get him out of there
right away or he's going to go night
night he's going to gas gas but get
knocked out cuz he's rushing forward
like sprinting forward it was so fun to
watch so fun to watch but uh Brunson
kept doing it Whitaker was calm cool
collected I've never I've never seen
like a championship kind of streak in
him to this point granted he won the
Australian uh and all that stuff but
I've never been like Whit yeah I've
never really seen him like as a huge
threat that night you're like okay well
this this boy has some serious T because
he weathered the storm and then just
landed a vicious cuz as brunson's run in
I think he hit him with a right hand
wobbles Brunson throws a head kick boom
finishes him off first round first round
round first round and then people go oh
Brunson that that why would you do that
kind of game plan but you loved him when
he was winning where were you when he
winning it worked Day times before now
would it work against the top three guys
no they're eat your dick up like kobashi
but it's gotten to this point which is
why we like him which is why he's kind
of a name uh but Whitaker looked amazing
I think what what I would do uh next for
him and I can't say this anymore if I
was Joe Silva because he's leaving this
December's his last month shout out to
Joe Sila but uh the whoever's the new
guy is I would do Whitaker ver versus
mousasi really that'd be the fight I
think and musasi just won I think com
off he just beat uall because remember
there's and he had a red redeem himself
cuz but he was winning that fight and
then your land that spinning back and
then he just destroyed him this time but
uh overall the you know and then Kyle no
who's fought 15E Career Training with a
guy great dude uh fun funny fact about
Kyle o he was security for the Crocodile
Hunter he was he was his personal
security really yeah so I watched that
fight I watched that fight when I was
yeah he looks good he looks very
muscular retired oh he retired retired
that was his last fight yeah last fight
his 15E career he was The Ultimate
Fighter coach one of the nicest guys of
all freaking time really I don't I don't
know if he same girl DME piece wife I
think sorry if it's your X he's super
stud like I said uh most people don't
know he was actually security personal
security and like helped train for the
crocodile for the crocodile hunter wow
how crazy is that but uh yeah great
career man and good for him tipped to
the hat to that guy for walking away uh
at the right time I think he's won some
big fights lost some fights but that's
how it goes life of a fighter good dude
but yeah Whitaker um mousasi is next for
him I thought I even tweeted and then
people were like how how about how how
how about uh the the technique of the
fight Whitaker's technique was
phenomenal he weathered the storm hands
were high really didn't eat a lot of
shots great Tak down the fence calm cool
collected in his backyard and Brunson
sprinting stuff like that you you can
say from a traditional standpoint the
technique isn't great but if you look at
other guys techniques who are wild like
uh you can't say Tony fer anymore cuz
his technique is the that last fight was
ridiculous but I used to compare him cuz
he's a wild guy but you got to remember
those guys are at such a high level for
them they have the fundamentals that you
speak of that you hate on trust me they
have them if you think you know
fundamentals and you think that guy
fighting in his underwear at the highest
level in the world doesn't know
him I you're you're you're so out of
line it's not even funny but those guys
it's it's it's chaos that's under
control they have the fundamentals so
Brunton he looks like he's wildly out of
control and actually got caught for it
he's won a lot of fights doing that too
um but I but people were texting me how
about that technique I've seen better
technique on World Star Hip Hop and some
funny stuff so I uh put I retweeted and
put as my boy Brian K would say terrible
fundamentals
people oh God man it was a fun fight
though like I was like I was sitting in
my bed CU I watched um lenko where he
fought uh I think guy's named Taylor
either way talking with the
boxer HBO yeah great great first of all
gold medalist in the Olympics I believe
but he only has seven Pro fights he
fought a guy who's 30 and0 now listen to
this and you you a lot of people
probably haven't seen the fight he made
the guy quit but not from damage he was
he outclassed him so bad I think it was
in the fourth or fifth round he looks at
the ref goes oh I'm done not hurt
nothing just goes I can't cuz he was
just so out class he couldn't do
anything lenko was just destroying him
angles and the guy and the ref goes what
and he goes I'm done no and so what so
they interview uh obviously they
interview lenko and he's doing his thing
I think what's next for him is probably
Manny Pacquiao he needs a huge name
fight which I think you absolutely
destroy anyone to me pound-for-pound
he's the number one by far in the world
now the argument is okay so Demitrius
Johnson's number one in the UFC lenko is
number one in boxing but they're so
small the risk of losing is way less
than a guy like uh like uh Kan Velasquez
like the Jon Jones like Michael
because because the guys aren't big so
they can make mistakes and not get
knocked out get finished where at higher
weight classes the chance of getting
finished are way higher right so that's
why I don't rank yeah their margin air I
don't rank them one right I don't they
that's fair that's fair skill-wise
they're number one yeah pound-for-pound
they're not number one but um I know
it's a little bit contradicting but
lenko i' I've never seen it so this guy
fighting world class he's worked his
whole life to get there he ruined
everything he's ever worked for in 27
minutes because now and and Max
Kellerman who's literally my favorite
analyst in the game shout out to Max
Kellerman him on first take he's such a
beast man he's my favorite guy to listen
to by far he's interviewing him and he
asked the question he goes man were were
you even hurt like I've never seen a guy
just kind of wave the White Flag his
Corner didn't do it he did it that's how
out class he was and he goes uh he had
to think he goes well no I I was hurt
you know but you can see on tape he
really wasn't hurt granted that's his
word he was just frustrating but uh m t
goes well in our Sport and a lot of the
people are going to critique you and
criticize you you kind of you're a boxer
you're a fighter like you go out on your
Shield Man you give everything you got
you didn't give everything you just quit
and there's part of me as a fighter goes
Jesus Christ that's terrible like dude
you're you're done no no no one's going
to want to promote you it's over it's
over as a fighter when you quit your
corner probably should have done that if
that's the way they felt you look at the
Kell Brooks fight which they he didn't
want to stop they stopped
but he he
had so his Corner price should up when
he does it everything you ever worked
for it it's out the window all the
respects it g now me as a guy who's
aware of CTE and brain trauma I go okay
well he was really outclass I can see
how he's kind of like I'm done well
maybe he said I'm just not ready for
this opponent yet because I I was
watching uh there's a YouTube thing on
lenko which says the tricks he's got
five different things they were breaking
it down and you see
how how he mixes everything up what an
artist he is he's he's it's like a
tapestry like the way he he will confuse
the [__] out of you in so many different
ways it's beautiful to watch and when
they break that down you have such an
appreciation for the technique of boxing
for a Layman when you watch that you go
like you realize how intricate and how
huge it
is Pros could watch that and not pick
it's like like domic Cruz I someone goes
is there any way you could learn like
Don M Cruz or TJ Dill I'm like no no but
you're an athletic guy I get that that's
what they do that's their thing chance
picking it's a form of artistry like
they're they're painting a tapestry the
way they the way they get you to commit
the way they get you to make mistakes
the way they get you to think that
they're doing something by by like you
know holding his right hand up exposing
baiting you in all those things and he
changes it all up so you can't you know
your brain isn't working that quickly
the thing is what sucks for lenko is
like that wasn't even fun to for me I'm
like Jesus Christ at this level this
world class level just it's not it's not
even how does he good do against
Pacquiao I wonder I think he destroys
him really I don't think Pacquiao
touches him now really but he but to get
into the mainstream he has to fight a
big name he's so good is he small is he
smaller than Mayweather yeah he is oh
yeah oh yeah but he he can go up you
know what I'm saying um he him and
Pacquiao can fight a catch weight for
for sure those Russians man they've got
an incredible program they stay in those
amateur ranks they'll fight 300 fight so
yeah exactly so they're ready when they
get there so I I watched that and then I
was like I record the UFC fight that
fast forward I watched Kyle's last fight
cuz shout out to Kyle and then uh I got
to the main event and I almost woke my
baby up man I was like screaming it was
such a fun fight you talking about Lono
you're talking about the I'm talking
about Brunson Whit such I was like ah
cuz let's be honest the card was kind of
lackluster so I'm like all right
whatever when I first T was two women
figh I didn't know so I was like all
right whatever right um the fun funnest
part was probably they were they were uh
bisbing on the the UFC tonight on the
they interviewed him like what do you
think these guys it's it's true he's
like uh I had to Google both their names
just to figure out who they were and who
they fought last let's be honest here
he's like he's like they're great
they're good Fighters but I I I don't
really know who they are I when when it
com word is he's fighting Yol Romero uh
June in Anaheim well that's going I
don't know if that's confirmed or not
what little birdie told me yeah I mean I
don't care if we go I I predict that
you'll you know in all due respect to
Michael bisbing he's awesome but you
know I've been saying it but um I I
think y beats him I think Yol beats him
just on sheer athleticism and and he's
just you know he's got he's on a nine
fight win streak let's bet uh we'll
definitely bet on that uh definitely I
got bisbing um and that's a good bet
it's a smart bet because because bising
doesn't get tired puts a crazy Pace on
incredibly Technical and Y if you'll you
know if we're talking four and five
round four and five now against Michael
bisbing with that pace you're going to
have your hands full with Michael bising
three four and five the pce set very
good bet a good bet I'm taking that all
day I would imagine bisbing is the
favorite in Vegas too I'm just saying as
a as a analyst or call me whatever you
want in my professional opinion I think
it's the best matchup for bisbing when I
first saw it I was like God it's a
terrible fight for bisbing and I started
thinking I'm like ah bis Bing's boxing
is really good God his footwork his
anti- wrestling is amazing he does not
play that game yeah the reason the
reason why Chris got in trouble is cuz
he played that game well because you
know and you they were talkinging like
here's the single leg here's the single
leg I keep feeding it to you and oh
you're going for it again bad bis
doesn't play that game he doesn't he's
very smart Against the Cage he's going
to circle out he's he's look at the
great wrestlers he's fought yeah and
granted he hasn't fought a guy to y's
level but you look at the you look at
the middleweight Division and it's by
far to me it's is his best match up
maybe maybe the thing about yoel I think
is that because of his explosiveness and
his athleticism
those three rounds are so precarious
that if you make one mistake right when
you make when you make that mistake now
guess what scary the the guy that we
always forget about and I always forget
about two guys in the 85 pound Division
I forget about gagar Massi I always
forget about him he's like the Invisible
Man yep he's like the Invisible Man can
beat anybody on any given day okay and
then there's Mr Tim Kennedy who actually
beat Yol I mean and then you know yeah
then there's that but a guy who is
everybody's strong does not get tired
not the same striking but yeah yeah yeah
no or even maybe wrestling but his Pace
you know Tim's Pace his his strength and
his Pace um well he's got to be
frustrated uh well he has a fight now
Kelvin G him that's if the commission
does nothing for you does it isn't that
weird yeah and I love Rashad in New York
versus Kelvin now Kelvin it's almost
they're almost disciplining him I think
because they go you didn't make weight
here you go check this out oh oh you you
like the you're grind
oh you a grinder that's you a grinder
sir and you're not making way you
grinder check this out this what we're
going to do with you so here's Tim L
Cino Kennedy exactly what I said here's
Tim Kennedy cuz a giant because
everything you do he does better oh no
and it's in Toronto and this is the
other thing yeah if you lose we're
probably going to cut you watch man dude
it's what I said I went when I saw that
I went come on guys Kevin Gast is a
great guy he's tough as [__] misses way
too much guys there's nothing could you
have given him somebody other than Tim I
mean I middleweight in a little bit here
Tim Kennedy oh and he's a chopping at
the bit to get in there and he made
weight still just to prove a point Kevin
gam is a sturdy powerful man and then
when you see him next to El Capitan when
you see him next to El Capitan oh oh you
talking about America's Finest you're
talking about the naked chimp you're
talking about the hairless chimp oh it's
it's like it's like you and you and I
beloo and whatever his name is Joe book
He's The Elephant when he walks in you
and I kneel down you're damn right every
American should damn right KN down no no
no well there's yeah there there are men
well hold on there are men and then
there's Tim Kennedy they're they're
they're men they're boys they're men
then they're they're the special voces
then there's Tim Kennedy then there's
Tim Kennedy I cried for that man you
cried that's how good of an American he
is yeah there's Tim Kennedy godamn Tim
what Tim will do is Tim will go do tip
of the spear [__] in the military and be
arguably number three number two
contender in the world at the 85 pound
division UFC and the other thing is
he'll host a show on the History Channel
called hunting Hitler he do that too
I'll do that too do that too go hunt
he'll go hunt Hitler for you how does TV
show it's a sheep dog it's a sheep dog
by the way loves his church loves his
wife loves his family loves his country
I'm in Austin uh for their jiujitsu
tournament with and doing play-by-play
with Eddie Bravo hopefully Tim's there
then I don't know if that's oh you know
what he'll be his fight's December 10th
yeah yeah I'm in [__] Austin the 9th
I'm going to miss Tim Kennedy damn it
he's always smiling he's the nicest guy
ever saw you think you'd have pts took
my hand my face in his big Ms took my
face in his big killer Ms and kiss me on
both cheeks they did those Ms have ended
some lives let's be real here they've
won a lot of fights theyed some live up
up close and personal dude he smelled
their breath is he the greatest American
you know listen man there it's hard to
argue right I got I got a list of well
but Tim Ken Tim Kennedy I got I got John
Stewart I like Alec Balwin I like Brett
Favre but I like Tim Kennedy farre and
Tim Ken well all right well this
conversation's
over the guy who took a dick pick in
Crocs well I kind of like the guy that
went from Green Bay to the Vikings kind
of like him for all that here's the
thing here's the point I'm making dick
with
that ends it for me you can't be a great
American I got I got Tim let me guess
you you like wiener too well look I told
you I'm shedding my shed my scales okay
well you're
out mold
snake snake shed my scales you don't try
to harness me don't try to keep me in
there I can't can't like a little nub in
Crocs can't like a little nubby nubbing
CR the worst and he sent to the lady at
the front desk you got you walk by her
every day but also don't if I'm going to
send a dick pick I'm going to be 10 Hut
I'm going to be stretching that skin but
with the what he's working with you
don't send a dick pick I got an idea
send a picture you throwing a goddamn
touchdown that might do the job with a
heart on well it's going to be tough cuz
not or go ahead and mix it up Bulldog
your nuts bend over bend over in your
jersey something you don't s a picture
put your cleats on bulog you nut that
guy he pulled that guy out after he'd
been for a jog and he was all scrunched
up like a turtle head there's no you
know why did he do that cuz he didn't
take my [__] class on Dick your
Workshop I know I got too but the thing
is is he goes all right what's the least
how can I just make her dry all right
put on these [__] Crocs and I think
even had like one of those like you know
how they have the the badges on them
like one those weird girly badges he had
a bush and then white as [__] legs it
may as well been a dead baby bird that
didn't make it out of the nest okay am I
right what you do next time is you get
that bird reaching for the Sky you get
him up you get him up and out of the
nest even if it's a small bird you get
him get him get reaching you oil up you
oil the sh I think you get creative hold
on I'm going to tell you then you get
that camera under the balls you get the
camera under the balls okay now you're
working angles now you got a friend of
yours who's got tiny hands you get those
hands and you act like it's your hands
because Brett's got some big hands and
then you get your friend to have those
hands kind of hover over over the head
of that big old that well that really
want some B aage you want some kid hands
you got want some kid hands so you get a
doll then get a doll okay I was going to
say you can't use a real kid cuz you get
go to jail for Chris excuse me sir what
are you doing Chris Hansen comes out you
don't want that you get a doll with
those tiny little hands you just kind of
like it's like holding them she's like
good God this is the prom she's like oh
my God that's a big old piece sir and
you're in the Hall of Fame I'm game then
you come on over and she goes what the
[__] man trick photography phography you
seen Avatar [__]
H you seen Avatar [__] you ever seen
Jurassic Park t- rexes are real no hey
that was 3D but it's fun that's all it's
still fun I us I'll put in work I used
my zoom lens and you fell for it but I
got you here while you're here while
you're here oh I'm sorry for dinner you
never you Snapchat before it's a filter
yep I I didn't realize you look that big
paid for dinner don't be such a size
queen yeah don't be don't be a hater on
small dicks small dick I got strong hips
small penises matter lady and then she
Ratt at him I think she blasted that
dick pick out that's terrible how mean I
know
there I have taken pictures of my 10 Hut
and my hand will be on it and I go I
don't like the contrast I'm take the
hand away cuz your hand all weathered
like no also the hand the hand makes it
look smaller than I want it to look I
want it to yeah but let's be honest it's
also like like your hands like this old
kind of like old old like Grandpa hand
like a grand Grandpa hand yeah you know
like a weathered hand I got some
arthritis in the joint in the knuckles I
can't put my hands in either I got like
scars on and stuff she's like God damn
my hands look like [__] I don't know man
you know what I do sometimes when I take
a dick pick I'll get a black man's hand
on it I'll get a black man never met you
talking about chocolate hand I'll have a
friend of mine I have a black friend of
mine grab grab my own grab my white dick
and that's a nice contrast I'm I've
never met the the old Coco Krispy hand
attack I'm like listen up bro you're
straight I'm straight you're a black man
I'm a white man going have you grab grab
a handful I'm going to give you I'm
going to put 50 bucks in your PO in your
pocket yep cuz I know just on principle
so you don't feel like you're doing it
for free cuz a man a man wants to feel
like he's straight go ahead and grab
yourself a fist full don't don't squeeze
too hard or actually do squeeze actually
do squeeze too hard Want You To herniate
The Head want it to be a little bit
purple so it looks even bigger yeah I
like that vein to get a popping there
you go pop that out go go ahead and get
that chocolate hand in there I caught
the old the old chocolate hand you call
it the chocolate hand trick mhm I call
it chocolate filter chocolate hand
effect it's a new uh it's a new SnapChat
thing I like it that would be a good
thing like if Instagram was not even
Instagram if Snapchat was doing a that's
a good business there you go you got for
because let's be honest guys send dick
piics so let's say you come up with an
app that maybe it mixes it up with the
dick so it's not so creepy maybe it has
a bow tie on it maybe it's like it comes
with a dick in a box so it looks like a
gift and maybe you click it and Bo
what's this maybe it looks like The
Lochness Monster peeking out of the
water you have all these fun filters
it's called Dick filter it's called Dick
filters dick filter F filters now listen
I got an even better idea you get a
friend of yours who's a little person
okay now I don't want to be but you know
little people I don't know what the
correct term is but a little person
little person he can't say dwarf or
[__] you guys know what I'm talking
about yeah we get you I'm not going to
use the d word but you know they got and
we all know that their hands are tend to
be a little bit smaller you get thick
though thick but you get that you get
you get a hand one of those hands I got
a friend disagree I got a friend thick
nah grab grab a hold the base what
happens is but the hand's not as big
grab a hold of the base there's a whole
lot left over and now yeah but you can
tell like you're like what what's wrong
with handsome over here why is why is
this thumb so big it looks like a little
tin you know what it looks like it looks
like one of those White Castle little
hamburgers with just four fat weenies
hanging out you know those little weener
dogs yeah but I don't have a White
Castle dick all right we've been talking
about this way too long well but I think
it's important grown men we are the
point is how about the dick needed to
take how about the dick out that's a
good idea God damn it someone's for sure
going to do it by the way that's a
really good idea that you can dress your
dick up for dick piics I'm surprised
it's funny dick piics they might have it
already but not funny but they help guys
out the right the right lighting they
have effects on it I'm being dead
serious that's actually an amazing idea
ah thank you well we just did it how
many guys would do that if you could put
reindeer like if you could put antlers
on the end of it or big old eyes on it
or you put like you have elephant ears
hanging out and then the trunks's uh
gray that's so funny to me you have like
an octopus and it's like leg octopus oh
dick oh that's funny but that's so
disgusting why would you have legs at
the B of it you don't know what people
sorry about my tentacles they tend to
they'll tickle your be Bean they'll fill
with your bean well that's so gross
isn't it weird though yeah didn't you
say you were talking about how when
somebody bent
over and they had they had hemorrhoids
you were like did somebody did somebody
put a bunch of earthworms in a headlock
yeah oh we're talking about will sass
disgusting oh yeah that's right we did
bunch of hemorrhoids you ever had a
hemorrhoid sir uh once it was so you had
let me cuz I I was in Denver Colorado I
was lifting heavy weight heavy yeah
we're talking
about this was this was big brown but
like real you're doing football weight
we football weight I got some love
handles I'm sweating all the time I got
a weird weird fro going I'm eating
whatever I want I'm deadlifting the
Gazoo all I care about is getting swoll
the [__] up you're not a good wiper not
a good wiper but um I'm driving and I
get the
most intense itch in my [__] like I'm
like
I was driving I was like yeah [__] son
yeah you need a you need an ostrich nail
you need an ostr nail [__] I need a
[__] Velociraptor claw in that
[__] I swear to God I almost crashed
my car at the time at I Cadillac uh CTS
I'm [__] driving like oh my God oh my
God I I mean I go I don't I don't go
finger to [__] I went through the
underwear that small filter that small
filter you're still going to your hands
going to smell like [__] let's be real
we have all been there but I still
reached in there and I scratched that
thing like it would like my life
depended on it I like God damn that
feels good well guess what that itch
went huh oh really oh we're going to
turn the flame on oh we're going to turn
the flame on because now it's going to
go from really itchy it's get itchier
now it's going to burn Jesus and then I
was like hold up is there is there a
snake coming out of my [__] no
Brendan that would be a hemorrhoid sir I
have to get in the miror you know
I to B over like a bad porno look
between my legs it looked like there's a
grape coming out of my [__] a grapes
like a purple gra really a purple grape
a purple grape and what do you do about
that is that a vein what is that that's
a vein that protrudes through the anus
oh Christ so what like like Tremors it
looked like the movie Tremors coming on
my [__] so I had to take the old the
old one two digit and just go ahead and
not up in here push him back in you had
to push him back in I went ahead and
pushed him back in well they don't like
that bro science right there bro that's
Bro Science I went you know what you're
poking out I'm going push you in he went
oh I'm going in but guess what this time
I'm coming with friends now three of
them came out he went we're going to go
away oh no we coming back with friends
now there's three of us hey guys I'm
having some resistance I need some
backup I need
backup stick your head in there push me
somebody get my heads from push me
through three of them there a
three-headed monster no now that
itching you never you never felt pain
brother now you have to go to the
hospital sometimes yeah I thought I was
going to have to but I was super
embarrassed so I did some research now
when you do bro research when we talk
about Bro Science can I can I say can I
can I guess scary rabbit hole can I
guess put some ice on that bad boy no
there's like preperation H use wipes
don't lift real hard uh try not to [__]
so much don't Jes don't sit on the
toilet for longer than you have to drink
lots of water now F they always say
drink lots of water that's going to help
my
[__] but hole drink a lot of water
make sure you're hydrated my my that
that'll cure the giant
grapes that that Mediterranean that the
bunch of grapes wine maker you look like
a [__] wine maker it looked like it
looked like [__] uh Gabby's
Mediterranean food was hanging out of my
ass just olives olives olives he came
back with friends oh dude huh like take
my take my index we got a fighter here
we got a fighter here and they [__]
came up need back up so so I and people
I you know on the form stuff they're
like I had I had to have surgery to tie
it off and cut them like good God lucky
for me I chilled out used the wies
haven't been back since wow I know now I
I'm very aware I've lost every lady
listener I've ever had and they probably
block me on Instagram right now I'm
disgusting n but every guy I don't care
who you are you've had an itch in your
[__] and you've you you've used your
meundies or whatever briefs you're
wearing to scratch that and that [__]
does not care my my this when you know
you're married my wife I I bent over I
had what I thought was a h and I bent
over and I go look at my butt just
joking around cuz I'm attractive and
that's how I do so I'm sure she L and I
peeled the old Peach and I said that's
my butt and I was just being you know
generally a [__] the way I am yeah I
was probably no I was younger I was
probably 46 and uh that's accept yeah
and she goes Brian I go what she goes
you have a hemroid and she ran out of
the room and I was like I do that's what
that is cuz I would get crazy itch it's
a nightmare I was cuz I was squatting up
to 190 uh hand me that water please
would you would you rather have an by
the way Rea Maria are engineer is
laughing her ass off that's a good
giggly gig well she's like I can't wait
for this she and she's a good-looking
woman and we're we're talking this have
you uh would you rather have an itchy
[__] that intense for the rest of
your life or a runny
nose God that's a good question God is
there anything worse the snot-nosed kid
in school you know what's worse snot
noos kid in school the snot-nosed grown
ass man trying to get work done I don't
know I I guess your nose is constantly
red you kind of get those snot bubbles
when you don't realize what's going on
problem I might have to go with my
[__] but then you got youve never had
the itch that I've had brother no that's
terrible you you haven't walked the line
I've walked cuz you would be like I'll
take runny nose God it's a tough
challenge though is it I don't like
having a runny nose though ity [__]
you you're uncomfortable throughout the
day nose is so visible you got to keep
blowing running nose is terrible yeah
you're always
this yeah listeners hated that I don't
know either way if you've walked the the
life I've had with that ass why don't we
go ahead to why don't we move on we've
covered events we cover we've lost every
listener we've ever had we covered
important events on a Monday I feel like
we're back to life though you know like
we're back to kick and when I say
kicking I mean being ourselves agree uh
you want some current events Brian the
kid count our new producer be doing this
our new studio I've been running the
helm right now I'm impressed you're
doing everything well don't be that
impressed let's hear these events first
uh so we'll get into you know what we'll
save the UFC ones uh for the end my
Colorado buffalos are in the Pack 12
title game I and it's in uh at Levi
Stadium in Santa CL I was thinking about
going up there I can't some of my boys
are going up so University of Colorado
played uh Utah who's ranked number 22
the winner of that well no if you if
Colorado were won they're in the Pack 12
Championship which the big deal I think
we're ranked number seven or eight now
if we win the Pack 12 Championship who
we play Washington who's number four or
five then we're we we'll go to a huge
ball game chance we could even get in
the the bull um championship series big
big it'd be tough but they could do it
but CU hasn't been good when I left
there we were good but not this good
this is the first time that and you got
to remember last year they're the worst
in the division the worst this year
they're the best that's insane man so
remember those seniors have dealt with
some shitty times now they're ranked you
know top top eight which is amazing man
so they beat Utah and then now uh this
week they play Washton number four I was
going to go but if they win that I'll go
their next good chance they go the rose
take that' be fun be fun get some
sideline passes yeah shout out to the CU
buff I was watch I watched that Buckey
game because I thought it was Urban
Meyer and I saw them come back that was
really cool good game yeah great game uh
I see now I like obiously I always root
for C I played there that's my that's my
team I love Ohio State because of urban
Meer I love and this going to sound
weird I love Michigan because I'm I'm a
huge fan of Jim Harbaugh it's not
obviously the rivals I like Jim Harbaugh
because he's every program he's ever
been to he's been a winner feel school
about him complaining about the
officiating that's fine that's what you
get that's like um part of the game it's
part but that's what you get when you
sign up to work with him like like for
me he's an emotional guy
like like with me like I'm a passionate
emotional guy that gets us to where
we're going it can also but it's also
like that that's what you signed up for
so like when my agent was like hey man I
don't think you should tell the listener
what's going on with Fox I'm like that's
what I do man that's like telling me
don't Don't Be Yourself I'm like but why
that's what's going on in my life that's
why the show that's why we're at where
we're at I will never compromise that so
going back I know I made it about myself
but going back to Jim harbot he's so
passionate and that's why he gets such
big recruits cuz they love playing for a
guy like that so he's on this win you
know he's always winning he's always
winning wherever he goes he always wins
he had some rough years although he went
to the Super uh San Francisco blah blah
blah um so he's had some rough years
great years but you can't complain with
a guy when he criticize the refs like
he's so passionate and they're to be
honest there's some terrible calls yes
and they get fined the the NCAA is such
a crooked scheme is it oh my God
everyone makes like how how weird is
this and I'm glad they're getting paid
but
Jim
Harbaugh had a commercial during his
football game so he's getting paid as a
celebrity outside that he gets paid more
money than God to be the coach the
player players can't have a commercial
during that right these are the guys
risking their lives risking their health
they're the that bring the money most of
them don't make it to the NFL don't get
an education no but and then think if
because they have an amazing player
peppers on their team top five player in
the nation first round draft pick he
can't have a commercial but Jim Harbaugh
can how when you retire like when when
Tim tibo's out of college um will he get
uh and they still sell his jerseys does
he get money no still no the university
does wow he gets no money amazing he
make his own yeah but that'd be kind of
silly and he can't use the Florida
things uh what else we got oh so this is
interesting uh we were talking about
Warden uh kovalev right yep how manyer
how many pay-per-views do you think it
was well that's that's a good question
because I would imagine it's much less
than I would think think only because if
you love boxing you were very excited
about that fight but I don't I still
don't know how big of a name either one
of them of course is it weird but the
thing is is they're both two of the best
in the world you know top five
pound-for-pound wherever you want to
rank him that top five but they're just
they're not like they're not we live in
the day and age of entertainment like we
Floyd Mayweather was a huge draw his
fights were the most exciting but boy he
talked a great game Money Mayweather all
that so we tuned in K McGregor great
talent knocks guys out but he talks the
that's why his pay-per-view numbers are
bigger than anyone's uh they're saying
it's probably around
uh see I see I think it h it falls on a
little bit of HBO because if you don't
want to pay the $70 to watch HBO you
know to watch a pay-per-view you know
HBO puts their big boxing matches on the
fallowing weekend so people can see it
so it's like well yeah I'll find out the
results but I'm just going to watch it
next weekend save my $70 if you're stra
for cash or whatever like the UFC Waits
a while before they release their
pay-per-views for a good reason HBO
always does that like you could just
watch it this past weekend right so they
they they think it's around uh
140,000 God that's not a lot it's crazy
right at
all that's amazing isn't that weird I I
was surprised I was a little surprised
but you just don't hear again it's hard
to pronounce kovalev's name it's that
that same thing it's difficult to I but
yeah I mean but the the thing Triple G
be a bigger draw no he's well you know
what he's a bigger he's a bigger draw
than 140 barely though not really he's
not fought he might have fought bigger
names not bigger names but he's far
Triple E but he's a Triple G is a
knockout artist but again talk he's very
respectful which for whatever reason our
society doesn't work look at our
president that doesn't work that doesn't
make headlines it doesn't make our
headlines whoever shouts the loudest
usually gets the most attention so
[__] true um that's a really good
point so with Andre Ward Kev Triple G
they're all very resp respectful which I
love Yeah ENT it's not entertaining like
would you want your your movie star very
humble and just does the job I'm not
watching that [__] movie yeah I need
him to be pretty outlandish you want
color you want color but people want
color Americans do there's too much
there's too much like results like you
know they like a quiet assassin they
like a guy who exactly app look at uh
Klitschko he could walk down Venice
Boulevard right now and not one person
surprise stop him he's he's been a great
heavyweight champ
no one gives a [__] cuz Russians are
understated they're pessimistic by
Nature Americans are optimistic by
nature and that's a function of their
their their history they've suffered so
much and they it's always [__] a man a
man doesn't you know you know that
Russians typically smiling generally is
not considered something that's friendly
you wouldn't just smile as Russian you
look stupid they it's it's it's
culturally I trained with arosi and
fought with
him youve train hated me I thought he
and they're like no it's just the way he
is I'm like oh that's nice yeah uh
schedule me dinner with him the first of
never um let's see here uh so did you
know the UFC forced Conor McGregor to
relinquish his featherweight title it
makes sense because he has no plans on
going back down to 45 so let them battle
it out you know that makes sense you
like that unless yes because unless he
wants to go back down and defend it you
can't hold it hostage he's a 55 pounder
now but I I think there's more signs the
UFC doing this them flexing on Conor M
force him to relinquish the belt granted
you are holding the division up I get
that part but now the fight for Conrad
Gregor and I said this before is with
WME and re Emanuel now it's not with
it's not with uh Nate Diaz it's not with
khabib it's not with Tony Ferguson
that's that's the easy work and granted
those are tough matches for him
business-wise that that's easy and
that's what he does now you're taking on
an Ari Emanuel a WME and you want to
stake in the in the business that's your
fight and I think they realize how long
and he's serious cuz he knows how
valuable is the company and well his
Market sh a little birdie showed me the
numbers of his market share how many
people like watch how important he is to
the company he's basically everything
and if I can see those numbers he can
see those numbers he dwars he dwarfs
anybody not even close yeah so his his
value and he knows his worth so he's in
that fight now so yeah you pull the belt
from him cuz they realize all right
we're we're in for a dog fight here cuz
he's not we pull the bellies and like
all right I'm come back and fight right
now like they're in a dog fight so I
think that's them realizing what's at
stake here all right well we got to move
with this division but it he so DC's
injured right do you know that D km's
out so his knee I'm not sure either way
he's out so they offered Rumble Johnson
a fight with mousasi and rumble's like
no I'll wait for DC probably smart
chances getting to to the title tough
especially at light heavyweight I'm all
I I respect Rumble for that so they're
making uh Anthony Pettis vers Max
Holloway the main event in Toronto and
it's for the interm title
but riddle me this if you strip Connor's
belt and you give it to Jose
Aldo why the [__] are they fighting for
intern because Jose Aldo I guess is
retired no no no no he's back he's yeah
they're giving him he's the champion
he's the title holder now okay because
they took Conor's belt gave it to
Jose and now have the interm belt is
that not weird it
is it is
um I don't know uh I I think because
because because remember Aldo and
Frankie fought for the interm belt at
UFC 200 maraldo Won that so that would
make him the intern belt
holder Conor McGregor the actual title
holder leaves so that would make the
interm guy the champion correct mhm mhm
is that is that not weird what's going
on here is they're creating and I It's
Entertainment so let's let's shift
through this honey [__] that's going
on I I like the business move I'm not
mad at this at all so what you're doing
is you're taking you're going to make
Max Holloway versus Anthony Pettis
intern belt holder obviously the the
winner of that will fight Jose Aldo to
connect the actual champion MH so you
can really Market two belt holders right
it's interesting right interesting man
but they you're right and now you're
dealing with ar Emanuel you're dealing
with his partner
they've been Partners I think since for
a long time since 2001 or something and
they have they have huge Ambitions to
create content I just read an article
about it create content be the creators
and the drivers of content the owners of
content I mean the UFC is just good luck
doing that without Conor good luck doing
that without that's the thing yeah it's
like I'd love to see the numbers on this
weekend's card I would too people they
don't care about just a fight you have
to they paid $4 billion there's a note
coming up they're going to have to pay
that back they borrowed that money I
would imagine so if the UFC is not
generating profits that are going to
honor that they may have way overpaid
somebody's got to be responsible for
that it's GNA be interesting a lot of
money and I don't think um I don't think
Connor uh gets a piece I think he
becomes uh the highest paid fighter of
all time to ever fight in mixed martial
arts I think they go listen we're not
giving you a piece of the pie what we're
going to do is we realize your worth
here's a $100 million to fight this next
fight yeah that's what's going to happen
he he'll get close to not as much as
Mayweather but he'll get for UFC for
what we're used to it's going to be
outlandish amount of money amount of
money he's already making probably 10
mil right more than that yeah yeah more
than that but still I I think he's going
to get upwards between 50 100 million I
bet for his next fight really you have
to he's he's that big of a draw provided
they're making that much a fight they
are off him off off content material uh
pay-per-view the gate they could easily
pay him that uh but I I like uh I like
uh pets versus hallay it's interesting
that because remember P has lost his
last two out of three yeah won his last
fight and then now he's fighting for the
interm title again it's about names
isn't it stars stars people are are
treated different and that's it's not KN
on UFC that's in every business like you
know they all think my business it's
your business it's it's it's you know
I've always I've been living that
forever you are not getting the part in
the movie if you don't have the kind of
market share that somebody else has oh
I'm a better actor who cares it's life
it it's capitalism think Max Hall won
nine in a row last fight he lost to
Conor McGregor by decision God so by
doing this and him being a main event
Pettis lost two out of three I love
Pettis but it's a it's a tough sell to
give him the interm title especially at
a new weight class I like it though I I
it's a tough It's a Max hallway Pettis I
mean we don't have to pick fights now
because you know it's a a week away two
weeks away a week away so we'll do it
next week but I like it I like I dude
for me Max Holloway you you have a star
and and you got to invest in them that's
the other thing I you're talking about
Max Holloway I am because Anthony py we
we know anthy we're familiar with weed's
box he's a former Champion the showtime
kick he he's established let let's shine
some light on Max Holloway but you can't
be just a main event that's not enough
yeah we we got to do something get him
on UFC and I I know he's in Hawaii but
you got you got to you got to do
something you the their publicist and
now you're with Ari Gold WME I sorry Ari
Emanuel WME they have the access to put
these guys in a different sort of light
to get the public to know them more you
got to invest in goly Max hallway
because why what why did Ronda and Conor
get so big granted they're winning
fights Hall's won nine I have a weird
theory on it but you have to invest in
them and blow that star up this is going
to sound weird but man I I I also think
that and it's a dicey thing to talk
about you know Connor and and Ronda are
blonde they're very they're good looking
they're charismatic they kind of pop on
camera you know Rhonda star Factor the
star Factor Rhonda is like her or love
hate her or love her Rhonda is very very
polarizing she's very vocal you [__]
and she's she's mean she and then and
then look at Conor McGregor you got a
guy when you have these silent assassins
when you have these guys like Max
Holloway who's just a great fighter who
is like just looks like a like a [__]
Junkyard Dog thin hard you know he's
he's not almost like Carlos Condit
Factor Carlos con is a very good-looking
guy Max is not so good looking Max is a
regular looking guy he looks like a
fighter rough guy it's just G I can I
know how those guys think I can see how
that's fair Brian you shouldn't be
criticized for because that's the same I
can see them saying he's not very enic
so we don't care as much all that stuff
well I agree yeah that's fine he doesn't
have that that he you know what it is he
doesn't have the it Factor when it comes
to Mark ability in the in the oon he's
amazing and don't be surprised if those
conversations are having are being had
uh they they were had when Dana took the
Dana's very aware of that he he's very
very aware of that that's what Dana is a
beast with that stuff he knows who's
going to be a star who's going to be a
draw so it Max all sometimes there's guy
a guy who was underused a guy who they
could turn into a star a guy that could
create marketability around is Tim
Kennedy and they don't do it enough they
could tap into that patriotism Factor he
falls in the same boat as me granted
he's a way better human being than I am
talks too much he he's too outp mind
he's too outspoken he won't get in line
if he doesn't agree with it and you you
can't put too much too many chips in in
his table he's not a company man it's
not even that he's not a company man but
he he does he's like if something's
wrong he's goingon to say some same with
me so for for us that that hurts you
liability it's a liability yeah but it's
should nurture it's great let him be
critical it's fantastic I agree people
love let him be go bad on the suits and
yeah not everyone wants the same thing
we'll be rooting for them I agree you
want to do one more or you want to move
on you want one more let's do one more
well it's just uh you know Misha
announced her um retirement and she
talks about the exact moment uh when she
realized that she was done and she says
going into the fight she was fine she
was like everything's all good you know
you're talking about uh uh strike Force
champion UFC champion she thought with
this win it's going to put her right
back in the title hunt and she was going
into the fight like everything was all
good and then in the first round she and
this is quote honestly I just knew after
the first exchange that I didn't want to
do it anymore I heard her say that so
it's kind of one of those things she
stuck it out she knew she had a lot more
to give but just wasn't firing and uh
she goes it's kind of odd to be honest
it's just lacking a little bit of
competitive Competitive Edge that you
still want to punch people in the face
and and dude I can I ever relate to this
cuz I told you my last fight granted it
was this perfect storm of things with
rebok blah blah blah but I'm I'm in the
back and I look at my coach I'm like I
just can't get up man I just don't care
just don't care and ask Tony goes are
you kidding me I'm like I don't know
what to tell you man damn but you you
you're hoping that it's just a phase
that when you hit the crowd and you get
in the cage it's like all right I'm
familiar with this those are just
negative thoughts and you tried all the
psychological triggers and all that
stuff I've seen everybody br as far as
mental coaches everything so it's it's
very strange and it's not that oh I give
up but it's just like I just don't care
I literally don't care I remember seeing
you in the octagon and you looked uh
like you kind of woken up from a nap
which I did I was taking a nap back just
look a little I was like hm he's a very
intense guy but he looks looks yeah I
was like he looks a little groggy and
you're hoping it just Fires for because
I've had I've had night like Gabriel
Gonzaga boy that I wish I was fighting
Brock Lesnar that night that's one of
those the they call it being in the zone
where the three rounds were over I'm
like really that's that was it damn and
then in my head I'm like I don't
remember doing that like who who was
that guy and I wasn't nervous going
through the flow anything you did I saw
a million miles away if you could
harness that every night but that that's
when I I wanted it [__] I want all I
wanted to win that fight get to the
title this is my life I'm a dog and then
I get a little money in my pocket I
start telling dick jokes with my buddy
I'm in the studio I make a move down
towards the beach hey dude we're having
cappuccinos cappucinos I got to go to
camp and I brought you with me cuz I
thought that would help me made it wor
that that was the biggest eye opener I
thought about that the other day that
was the biggest eye opener for me I've
ever seen because you barely warmed up
and you got in there and you had a
full-fledged fist fight kicking
wrestling punching [__] your neck up
with a 6 fo8 Jack May who looks like uh
like a superum when he walked in there
and I was like you have to to fight that
guy with a mohawk oh great who's going
to be trying to knock you out throwing
Haymakers kicking at you as hard I was
like well you kind of did some
stretching for about I counted it for
about three and a half minutes Jack mayz
right himself what's that Jack did none
Jack didn't even put on a helmet Jack
put on he threw in a mouthpiece and goes
let's fight and I was like what's going
on here and then I watched 500 plus
pounds of meat go back and forth and
then I watch you guys fall on your neck
he fell on Myck NE yeah that's how I had
the injury going to the and you had
trouble moving your neck I still have
trouble with my neck yeah you had
trouble moving your neck side to side
and had to keep training which I thought
was the craziest [__] I've ever seen and
swing I remember one time he threw as
hard as he could have right and you just
slipped it and came in for a double leg
I was like well there it is that's the
uh that was a Friday this a [__]
Friday we had to drive into the hood we
to drive into the hood crunch crch was
it what that be he whatever it was it
was whatever it was
aspect of it in black house and we're in
there and I'm and these killers are in
there and I'm like and you're you're
getting taped up and in walks the Giant
and I went that's what you do for a
living and you looked at me and you go I
go you're fighting him you go you want
to be a fighter huh I was like oh my God
that's what you do for a job I you have
a good time it's not moving around see
people think we're going to spar are
going to move around no no no no no Jack
was would get paid more if he knocked me
out with a head kick yeah yeah see he's
getting paid to try to knock and he's
trying to pay the bills so that's all he
wants to do
interesting life man well it's hard to
go from uh hanging out with your buddy
on Abby Kenny where girls in summer
dresses are getting by and you're
sipping on a
cappuccino
stroll get old sunde at salt and straw
to get into a [__] Shark Tank dude I
and I went change it for the world made
me who I am but I look back at it and
I'm like Jesus Christ well there is a
personality that is required for that so
whenever ever you get irritable or you
get intense it's what I expect because
it's part of your engine signed up for
yeah and it's a good thing but it's it's
uh it's it's a very very but some of the
things I learned through that experience
in football little but through
fighting I think helps me with my comedy
so much cuz I'm coming from an angle I
can't think of anyone else coming from
so it's all original [__] like you're
not going to hear what I'm talking about
on any special any Netflix just because
no comic can fake this you should you
should you should dilate and and
meditate on the mental fight that you
would have probably sitting in your car
before you were going to go and train
especially on Spar days like like i'
love was going on like the two
personalities in your brain one going
hey dude run away I've been working on
this bit because I want to do that
oneman show you know tell my story I
want to hear that yeah cuz the day of
the fight you you sleep horri that night
you'd wake up and like what time is it
well it's 7: a.m. okay um what's my call
time well you're on the main card so
you're not rolling until about
7:30 let's just hang out you sit on P
and needles let's think about everything
think about all the things that go could
go wrong well I would watch I would
watch video I would watch video though
so I'd get so nervous but in your mind
you would create this [__] monster
like if he oh my God he's beat this guy
he's done this but then when you
actually get down to the black and white
nuts and bolts I'd watch a video I'm
like well I've seen that I can do that
like my mind's crazy man my mind's crazy
he's not unable he's just a just a man
and you 66 yeah you were also sparing
monsters when when you when you were
sparring guys like you know training
with Andre lovsky and those kind of guys
yeah I mean I'm saying when you're
sitting in the car before you got to go
train got to go practice oh for sure and
your body hurts at the time though you
don't think like that cuz you have no no
other options it's what you do it's like
it's like the mailman he doesn't think
about it dog dog you're dog it's like
this this is oh you want to be famous
you want to make money you want to be a
professional athlete we're dogs and
who's going to make it out we're crabs
we're climbing on top of each other
who's going to make it out of the top
it's like the mailman like like the
mailman's not like all right I do mail
here here's your [__] mail here's
your mail I'm just driving here so as a
fighter it's like yeah of course I'm
going go there do that you only think
about it it becomes normal I I've always
I've been I've always been so ambitious
even as a kid it's the same thing like
with you on stage like for me right now
I'm n after acting school when I was 22
and I there and I saw all those people
in New York City who wanted to be actors
all those good-looking people all those
people and I remember saying to myself I
remember this so well I went I'm going
to be the one I'm going to make it out
of this I'm that never scares me that
never scar whenever like obviously
there's a million comedians out there
there's a million TV shows there's a
million podcast there's a million UFC
fighters million football players that
stuff never scares me that that
encourages me because I always feel like
I'm willing to do whatever whatever it
takes and and when those odds go less
than 1% of actors are working I get that
I get that I won't stop till the
difference I won't stop and I might not
make it but I know that guy's going to
stop before me if we're on a treadmill
his is going to break or some there's
going to be some issue that's right and
I just keep on keeping on it sounds
really weird but I've told you this I
went to Dan Gable's intensive wrestling
camp in Iowa with the hawkey and they
train you you know like a champ and all
I just remember because a third of the
camp uh even more they got shut down the
year after I was done cuz a third of the
camp or more they would drop out you had
to graduate from can't and it was the
only time that I I kind of was like I
don't know if I can make this I would
stare at my plane ticket you know i'
just be like I got to get out of here
not really because I didn't have a plane
but you know the point is and I I
remember just being like to a point
where I couldn't break but those those
those experiences where you just you
kind of one step at a time you look at
the it does it motivates you because you
go look at all these dudes somebody's
going to fall out today and I'm I'm not
going to somehow I'm going to make it
through yeah those those odds I think
people listen to those odds are you
you're in the wrong business you
shouldn't be talking about those odds
actually unless they motivate people
tell you those odds oh all the time but
I remember before I fought Roy Nelson
soone they're telling me the odds bro
you're only a A plus 125 I'm like why
the [__] would you tell me first all why
would you tell me that so many people
yeah but they're not on your side see
those kind of people and they're all
over the place and they exist in your
own family oh yeah those kind of people
are I'm sorry they're not your they're
just not your friends they they're not
helpful because why are they telling you
that [__] you're not if you want to tell
me something okay look you want to you
want to tell me something I love
criticism I do I like but you better
tell me how to get out of it if you're
going to criticize tell me I got odds
like that then then I want behind that I
want you to tell me I want you to tell
me how the [__] I'm going to get those
odds better otherwise keep your mouth
shut cuz I know hey hey hey I spent all
my time fighting that that animal I that
that ghost behind me going hey you're
not good enough what if you fa I I'm on
very familiar terms with that guy so
it's scary now I'm going to go I'm going
to go take a piss out of my huge dick
and I'm going to come back and give give
you a dropping knowledge boom all right
all right buddy go piss hard I need you
need you to secure my hips okay put me
in a choke cold all right you going to
drain the beaker yeah so I got a
dropping knowledge and it has to do with
something psychologist called the halo
effect the couple things the way your
brain works you got think of it as
having a system one and a system two
system one is the part of your brain
that arrives at conclusions right away
when you see something you have a
conclusion you see something and you go
like you can chunk information somebody
walks in with a knife and tear drops you
know you're like that guy's danger yeah
you we just we we immediately do that
stuff and there's a halo effect a lot of
times First Impressions so if somebody's
friendly you will a lot of times
attribute a whole other bunch of
characteristics to that person for the
rest of their life so you'll be like
that guy's friendly so he must give to
charity when you don't know anything
about it and we do this all the time and
what you have to do is be aware of that
that you will create a halo effect
sometimes somebody comes in and they
remind you of somebody you don't like
somebody you had a bad experience with
back in the day they might even have a
name that you don't like for somebody
you don't and what you'll do is you'll
just judge that person and attribute a
bunch of negative characteristics to
that person based on the first
impression so you're saying we're
already programmed to judge people based
off things that happened in our past or
that you associate negative it's called
the halo effect so be careful of doing
something like that yes so that's when
your system too has to take over say
hold it let me assess and let me get and
this is where I take getting other
people's independent assessments are
very important that's why when police
officers they don't want Witnesses
talking to each other because when
Witnesses talk to each other at a crime
scene they will arrive at the same
they'll arrive at the same conclusion
it's called confirmation bias okay this
is another thing human beings do all the
time we all do it you have a feeling
about something and you'll look at and
then what you'll do is you'll look at a
bunch of data and you'll choose the data
that conf confirms your conclusion
certain things that help your conclus
that that that'll support your
conclusion oh last night I was sitting
in bed gone there's a hater in iTunes
there you go there's a hater on iTunes
and he's he's not letting us upload the
episodes he doesn't want he doesn't want
us to succeed I was like you know what
I'm going to call iTunes tomorrow I'm
sit and you've attributed all that St
that negativity and then and I obviously
I'm just trying to point the aggression
somewhere and I talk to Mike he's like
no it's all good man yeah they upload it
and uh it just take time the internet so
we're moving as fast as the internet
went oh yeah that makes sense yep and
this is confirmation bias we do this
stuff all the time we will arrive at a
conclusion we will and scientists do it
human beings are very good at confirming
their bias okay and so be aware of that
always be aware of that you are going to
get a feeling if you don't like gays
you're going to find evidence in the
Bible that condemns gays if you think
being gay is okay you're going to say
well love thy neighbor and you're going
to find things in the Bible that confirm
that it's okay to be gay we do this all
the time we are always trying to
cherry-pick data that that supports the
way we feel already it happens in sports
because you look at guys like LeBron
James uh Russell Westbrook all these
guys they're known to get more fouls
than anyone else cuz the refs the
referees have a bias St okay he's
amazing probably missed that shot
because he got fouled so they get more
calls than anyone or guys like Tom Brady
you touch him oh you know the rule but
then there's guys like Cam Newton well
he's big he can take the hit there you
go he doesn't get as many calls that's
why Shaq didn't get called on as many
you know then then that's what we do all
the time so so just always keep the look
conspiracy theorists what do you think
conspiracy theorist do they do a couple
things one is that they will cherry-pick
all the data they can and that'll
support they're already they're already
suspicious they're already like there's
something going on there I feel like
Eddie Bravo was born in this world
suspicious like that's a red cranon he's
like Eddie the way all of us do suffers
from confirmation bias we all do it I
think Eddie has uh more of it than most
people but that is what we all do to an
extent we all suffer from degrees of
bias conf so make sure that you know
that your system one is going to arrive
at conclusions right away it's very good
at it that conclusion doesn't
necessarily mean it's true sometimes
it's good though like if you're good at
judging people like I can and I've me so
many met so many people now I can if I
meet someone I can find out right away
if they have bad intentions as far as
man should let me on your show to do
this or I you should you should hit me
up cuz I can help you with this I'm like
well I know what's going on here so do
you know you can do that with people's
faces do you know that people a lot of
times will avoid danger and women
especially they will not they'll be
aware wary of what do you think the two
features are big nose small eyes no not
bad cuz that's why they're terrified to
you and I no but you'll they'll be aware
of a strong chin and uh a frown that
that is that can be even a fake smile
you can see a lot of times but small I I
think smile
if grown man's walking toward me smiling
for no reason I'm running away from you
[__] or yeah now let me give you
an amazing let me give you an amazing
amazing stat here that I that blew my
mind as far as like being able to read
faces so what do you think is more
important when people look at a
politician do you think it's likability
or competence what do you think people
vote for they they want they want a guy
who has confidence competence competence
not confidence competence no I'm saying
they they need competent but and also he
uses confidence I'm saying with
competence meaning like he can get say
so what do you think is more important
likeability or competence uh this day
and age likeability okay so because I
feel like the election was God who meth
or cocaine like what [__] they both suck
they're both dangerous that's actually a
really good thing you know what I'm
saying like it's a very good point
believe it or not it's competence but
that this election is very good now let
me give you a stat that I thought was
fascinating so they this guy who's a
scientist at Princeton University he
showed his students pictures of men's
faces okay sometimes for as little as
one tenth of a second okay and he asked
them to rate the faces on various
attributes including likability and
competence okay so these guys all rated
and by the way these weren't just random
men's faces these guys were all people
running in real elections for governor
for Congress and for the Senate okay and
and then and then he basically did this
in Finland in Australia in Germany in
Mexico and in in um
Zoning Board elections in England okay
check this out now these people had just
they just saw the faces really quickly
sometimes for as little as a tenth of a
second and the ones that people voted as
being competent in that short a period
of time 70% of those candidates won
election 70% now think about that it was
so much of their face their facial
features we have we are hardwired we
have neural capacity essentially to
register what we consider to be
competence now it doesn't mean they are
it doesn't mean that you have a strong
chin and you have a competent smile that
doesn't mean that you are going to be
good in office but we have a
predisposition predisposition naturally
to read someone's face and say that
guy's a good leader or not there's
circuits in the brain that evaluate
dominance uh from the shape of the face
wired physical creatures just men be
careful of your first impressions ask
other lines of inquiry there's a good
chance the the next fireing the kid is
at the new official firing the kid
Studio we should finish up tonight um
but we can't thank the Network Studios
Mike and everyone involved for let us
Marie yes for your studio uh as you guys
listening this uh Tuesday night I am at
The Comedy Store doing standup uh Bert
ker Sam tripley uh bunch of ridiculous
comics on that lineup it's supposed to
sell out any minute now and December 4th
December 4th which is next Sunday Brian
Ken christalia and myself it's all stand
it's not fighting the kids show it's
stand up it's just stand up chrst Leah
Brian K myself that's at the comedy
store then that following Monday I'm at
the Laugh Factory we'll give you guys by
the way December 8 9 10 I'm at the Fort
Lauderdale Improv again always said it
my favorite place to perform love those
crowds then I got Phoenix the following
weekend stand up live it's okay because
people get backed up Phoenix stand up
live just know that so I'll see you out
there uh we got new Abbot Kenny Fight
Club hoodies dropping we got fighting
the kids sweatshirts dropping these are
by far best ones yet we have new fireing
the kid Army do you really want to bet
against us te's dropping and then the
original Abbot Kenny T's dropping uh
soon I'll give you guys follow me on
Instagram obviously always blast out
tk.com for anything you need episodes
number 208 with Will Sasso Brian K
myself episode 209 with Mattie mat and
myself are a able now on iTunes we back
and rolling in this [__] this is the
firing kid we're out
yeah